on the hill tonight four of the giants
will be anthony diesclopani lisa lafani
is 31 years of age he's in his eighth
year at the big league level
10 and four on the year with a 287 era
the thing about d scafani is when he's
on he can paint
both sides of the plate with all his
pitches
excellent command so here we go
chris taylor you've got the
shadows the dark shadows around the
infield and in left field
struck him out
a ball in the dirt buster scooped it up
and tags out taylor one away
two down and here is justin turner
here's a swing and a miss strike three
curveball got him a foul tip cozy held
on anthony d slavani with a couple of
strikeouts and he retires the side in
order happy 27th birthday walker bueller
builders faced the giants four times
this year six plus innings
zero or one run in all four including
going seven and a third and giving up
just one last thursday against them
comes home to alex dickerson out of
their own two offering
breaking ball gets him swinging and
finishes off a one two three first for
walker dealers two on two out
and now billy mckinney the eighth place
hitter tonight for la stands in mckinney
drove in the only dodgers run last night
with a base hit
mckinney hits a high pop up shallow left
dickerson got a very late break but he's
gonna get there and make the catch on
the run nice job alex dickerson dodgers
for the second ending in a row have two
base runners with one out
first and second one away for justin
turner
pitch
five to right towards the line goes
yaskrimsky won't get there
it bounces in and gives the dodgers the
lead
justin turner drives home chris taylor
and it's one nothing on a turner base
hit here in the third it jams justin but
he is a very good two-strike hitter and
a very good opposite field hitter and
this one chris taylor does a nice job
reading this ball
[Applause]
dodgers with something going here in the
third first and third one out and the
batter is will smith who's one for one
fastball ribbon to right center field
towards the gap that'll split it will
smith with extra bases
muncie in the score easily turner's
headed for the play he'll score smith on
his way to third with a triple
and the dodgers leave three nothing
and it triples ellie and it produces
just that
away and boy does he stay on it and
drive this baseball
that is not doing too much with it that
is just hitting it where it's pitched
and hitting it about as good as you can
[Applause]
wow the deflection off the corner there
just cams it towards right field and
makes it an easy triple
two gone for aj pollock two two to
pollock
chopper up the middle that'll pierce it
and get into center field to make it
four nothing
aj pollock scores will smith with a two
out base hit he's two for two
the dodgers who hadn't stayed multiple
runs in an inning in a few days have a
fourth spot in the third well the last
15 games aj paul has had 12 extra base
hits but right here a couple of singles
the second one drives in a run and adds
that fourth run
so ruff has a single giant second hit
here comes boston
grounder up the middle taylor to the bag
he'll throw to first a double play
second one turn by the dodgers behind
bueller tonight
well at this point in the game with
walker buehler on the mount only 65
pitches two outs on one pitch
and being able to get closer to the end
of a very quick inning
another way
for the dodgers maybe to get one less
inning out of the bullpen two gone bases
empty tyro estrada on this 2-2 from
mueller he watches a fast ball at the
knees for strike three five zeroes put
up by walker bueller walker bueller's
giving him just two hits he struck out
four and walked two runway first two
gone
and here's alex dickerson who's over two
in this one
another 2-2 dickerson went around the
ball's in the dirt it goes to the
backstop will smith can't find it
that's a break that is
a huge break
curveball
and it hits off the heel of the glove of
will smith he never saw it
so an easy
take of first base and the inning
continues
floors i mean he's looking for a mistake
middle end that he could drive knock out
the ball far put three on the board
quick
popped up
right side of the infield bellinger with
the call and the catch
first the third one go on the hitters
bueller
swings away bouncer to third vossler
coming home it's a tag play but the ball
comes out of his glove
the dodgers lead five nothing
it was gonna be bang bang the throw
might have been there in time it gets
into the leather but it doesn't stay in
the leather
first and third one out you're moving in
both bases
with the
ground ball you don't want them to be
able to turn a double play and not score
the run
no never only touched leather not ever
got in the catcher's glove with casalli
mckinney in second bueller first in a
2-2 pitch
muncie hits it on the line deep center
field duggar will turn and watch your
hit off the very base of the wall
mckinney and easily bueller's head at
home and estrada's throw will go into
second
two-run double for max muncie and
they've broken it open seven nothing
here in the seventh
[Applause]
well coming around from first and a howl
as he crossed home
this is a blast he gets another small
breaking ball in the middle of the play
back this one is all but
not far back that is a bullet
he hooks one down the line towards the
pole way back there and gone
bellinger with a home run
and the dodgers lead eight nothing
[Applause]
the fifth for bellinger as he continues
to make progress try to get his season
on track
ruff has one hit and three at
another one two from white
[Applause]
that is not a foul ball smith tracks it
down throws to first and ends the game
eight nothing the final score the
dodgers back to within two with the
giants in the west